[Music]
in the decade
of the 90s
remember way back in the 90s the 1990s
78 of the companies in america
did away with a pension plan and went to
the 401k
the only place you find pensions today
with rare exceptions is government and
union
there's almost no places have pensions
other than that that are substantial
so teachers policemen feds
whatever government and union it's the
only place you find pensions
and everybody was whining
and carrying on that corporate america
was not taking care of their employees
by doing away with the pension plans
and the truth is is that the 401k has
made more millionaires
than pensions ever did so it has turned
out to be
that when you invest money in your 401k
and sometimes your company matches some
upward of 70 of the companies do some
kind of a match
on a 401k you're in complete control of
that money it is owned
by you it does not get moved unless you
move it
it is not invested in something unless
you choose the investment
it is in your name and
it's portable meaning that if you leave
that company you can roll it to an ira
you still own the money
there's no special little gotchas like
pensions have or anything
so the 401k has proven over the last
three decades
to be a vastly superior
wealth building tool for the typical
american than the pension has
and that's not to pick on him he's a
policeman we appreciate his service i'm
glad he's got a pension that's great
but the point is that
uh this whole philosophy of you
are in charge of your life is
represented by the 401k
someone else is in charge of your life
and your dependent
upon them is represented by the whole
pension philosophy
and so it becomes golden handcuffs
and uh uh and you have to wait to get
your money you can't access it there's
all kinds of other things going on
so uh i am a huge proponent of you
investing your money so you end up with
money
that sounded deep didn't it yeah but i
mean really
there's a there's a real thing there
that you need to think through
who is in charge of your success
who are you dependent upon
that you can look at that person and say
you caused me to be successful
financially
become wealthy financially
there's only one he's in your mirror
no one's going to come to it for you and
if they do they're going to screw it up
you take care of
you that's simple
and that's what the 401k does that's why
i love it
it's made more millionaires than
pensions have made just write that down
this is the dave ramsey show